what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into our I guess
really completing the second half of
Ultimates this is when things get a
little bit hairy we're not really hairy
but when things get a little bit
interesting the reason why is because
again we're covering this as part of
Hickman's run going into like Avengers a
new Avengers to kind of set the stage
for a lot of that stuff and we'll
actually double back to some Ultimate
Universe stuff once we get further into
this but where this story ends and we'll
talk about this a little bit more where
this where the story ends as far as
hickman is concerned is around issue
number eight or so and then that's when
Sam Humphreys begins to pick up with his
run on ultimate so we'll talk more about
what that means with regards to the
actual story itself but again in the in
the last video what we had was basically
the rise of the city and the children of
tomorrow which is to say individuals who
were Heather evolution essentially sped
up inside this dome that was constructed
by Reed Richards of course ultimate Reed
Richards essentially became a bad guy a
little bit before this story picked up
but this is what he really becomes the
maker which is kind of like a full-on
villain now the idea behind this is that
what we end up doing it at least
initially end up doing is picking up
with a place called TM which is well
really I guess yeah I guess it's called
tian and only while different Marvel
it's called Newton but uh but basically
this is the Ultimate Universe version of
what amounts to basically Avalon and
what I mean by this is that in the main
Marvel Universe Magneto
long I guess really during during a
Chris Claremont run had tried on several
occasions to create a sort of paradise
for mutant kind which is say a place
where mutants could take up residence
and reside outside the influence of
humanity the most notable of which was
asteroid M or Avalon depending on what
you want to call it which existed out in
space but that's basically what Newton
is or I'm sorry what Thien is and this
comes out of something called seer now
in serie in the Ultimate Universe you
had what was called the Southeast Asian
Republic and the idea behind this was
that when when Nick Fury was the
original super soldier and Nick Fury had
basically vanished and the Steve Rogers
became the new super soldier and then he
was assumed to have been killed during
the events of World War two what this
did is it gave rise to a lot of
individuals or a lot of different
countries trying to create their own
super soldiers Cyr was one of these
organizations that was kind of late to
the game and it really wasn't until like
after ultimatum that Sears started
trying to mass manufacture individuals
with superpowers and so what they did is
they took a huge percentage of their
population and literally started like
injecting it with superpowers seemingly
at random to see what kind of powers
manifested and this led into a group
called the people which is basically
kind of like this coalition of
individuals who all had power
what you ended up getting was
essentially a rebellion among the
Southeast Asian Republic were those with
superpowers essentially annihilated the
seer government and then interned he and
rose up and this is basically led by
Zorn and Zorn
so you have X ORM and Z ORM and they're
essentially brothers now this is the
ultimate universe version of the me that
you have one version of Zorn who has
like vast telekinetic powers then you
have the other version of Zorn who has
like a black hole inside his helmet
meaning if he takes his head off it'll
open it'll unleash a singularity on
earth and we'll actually see that play
out here in a little while but the other
half of this is you you have tien really
responding to this and you have like
shields showing up to tian basically
saying hey look like the children of
tomorrow are going to come for you and
so we're looking for your aid here like
we're looking for your help and the very
least to warn you and to so we can use
your powers to kind of go to war against
the children tomorrow because you're the
most powerful force in existence at the
moment right now the issue with this is
that most of really a lot of the people
on tien are kind of isolationist we're
just to say you stay away we stay away
and so we don't really want to get
involved in this we don't really want to
have anything to do with this and so
while all that's going on in the city
proper what you end up having is the
Incredible Hulk who shows up and just
starts ripping everything to pieces now
at this point we kind of jump back about
17 hours before the current current
events in the story and pick up with a
guy named flume named Marvin Flum now
Marvin Flom was introduced as part of
Hickman's run he's new to this story and
the idea is that when well at least what
we're gonna go ahead and kind of
continue through this so you guys will
understand what's going on because a lot
of the stuff that's being done to
explain his character actually happens
over the course of this story but
essentially he met with Bruce Banner now
here's the important thing to bear in
mind ultimate universe Hulk is similar
but also very different to the main
Marvel Universe whole namely like he
eats people but the idea is that after
ultimatum during the events of like
ultimate fallout when Peter Parker died
and all that kind of stuff the death of
spider-man hit the superhero community
in a lot of different ways and what this
did is it allowed for Marvel to kind of
rework the Incredible Hulk and have him
basically just kind of go off live with
monks and trying to live some measure of
a peaceful life what happens is Marvin
Flum shows up and says you have to go
destroy the city and when the response
the Incredible Hulk is no there Marvin
Fleming says yeah but like if you don't
then like we're gonna kill Betty Ross
it's basically blackmail now because of
the fact the Incredible Hulk is is
really lives up to his namesake and this
tends to be very similar to his main
Marvel Universe counterpart in the old
with regards to the fact that he's very
unpredictable and he never really know
what he's gonna do he's got insane
levels of strength he is powerful enough
go through and start wreaking havoc in
the city and so when the city starts to
respond of course you have like all
these things kind of going nuts the
members of the city respond and of
course they try to take out the
Incredible Hulk as best they can but
they don't really stand much of a chance
because it's just raw strength and so in
response to this it's one of these kind
of brain meets broad sort of situations
when the maker tells everyone to stand
down and he in turn goes to respawn and
deal with the Incredible Hulk and again
that's when things really begin to pop
off when things really begin to go nuts
because when you had us he and and you
had their essential telepath go through
and try to like communicate with the
city and try to tell everybody in the
world what was going on Reed Richards
had hijacked a telepathic signal and
then used it to communicate directly
with with T and Proper and basically say
like we're gonna take everything away
from you like we're gonna conquer you
there's nothing you can do and then in
turn overload the mind of their telepath
and kill him that kind of sets the
ground for TN responding because what it
is is this an act of aggression now
where TN is one of these places were
again it's very much isolated as very
much we should we you know we do our own
thing do not bother us we're basically
the remnants of Seir and we don't really
want to be bothered by people it's
essentially a first strike on behalf of
Reed Richards and so will you really
have like all these super powerful
beings who all just immediately start to
go through and and basically attack the
dome proper now the issue with this is
that while all this is going on you have
a meeting with the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and the reason for this is because all
this really kind of comes down to the
failure of shield remember shield in the
Ultimate Universe is designed to be as
much a peacekeeping organization as it
is an organization that's designed to
function with action and actually like
engage in conflict and shield was
designed for the purpose of maintaining
peace across the world in place of
various governments or at least a kind
of orchestrate and maintain those those
peace treaties the problem is that
shield has basically failed and the
world's plummeting into chaos because
they've been totally unable to stop Reed
Richards and so in response to this the
President of the United States who's
basically Barack Obama at the time this
is written calls a meeting of Congress
some of the various you know of both the
House representatives and the Senate
itself and what's happening here is he's
executed the winter protocols and what
the winter protocols do is they allow
for shield to target the ultimates and
specifically Nick theory for shield a
fall under the control of Marvin flump
and in turn like become an enemy of the
superhero community and so when that
happens like Tony Stark Thor all the
members of The Ultimates Nick Fury
himself they're all now public enemy
number one and they're all being tracked
down by shield so think of this as a
Ultimate Marvel counterpart so like
order 66 from that disastrous Star
prequel trilogy in the midst of all this
we really kind of switch back to Reed
Richards and Incredible Hulk now this is
something I've kind of wanted to talk
about for a minute this is what makes
ultimate Reed Richards so dangerous his
ultimate Reed Richards it's kind of the
answer to the question what if main
Marvel Reed became a bad guy and what if
he was twice as good with his tongue as
he is with his brain and so really like
when he starts talking to the Incredible
Hulk it's basically like look man you're
being used like the government never had
any intention of handing Betty Ross back
to you all the federal government knows
is how to strike but that's basically
because everybody in the US federal
government are just a bunch of dumb
asses and so because they're basically
idiots they don't really know how to
feel with someone on an intelligence
level of my level you know who's as
smart as me and so they're going to do
exactly what I predicted they would do
which is launch an attack and that's
exactly what the government does when
the president steps off and starts
addressing Congress what he essentially
says is two things one I've executed the
winter protocols which means now shield
is under the direct authority of the
United States government specifically
with Marvin Flum acting on our behalf
and two I've launched a full-scale
strike against Reed Richards and when
the questions ask what have you done the
response to the president is I've
launched the entire nuclear arsenal of
the United States every single nuclear
weapon we have is targeted towards that
city and we're going to try to destroy
it as best we can but that's the crazy
thing about this is that ultimately none
of it works and it goes exactly the way
we thought it would when you basically
have like the city fully prepared for
that that's really what Reed Richards
was hitting home at that the federal
government lags behind but the federal
government is afraid that somebody will
come along and take its power the city
is so far advanced that in the face of
overwhelming odds the government will do
the only thing it knows how to do which
is attack not think and so Reed is kind
of like we'll just go with the flow we
can easily withstand the entire nuclear
arsenal of the United States because of
what use would a city this advanced be
if it couldn't defend itself and then
once we deal with this onslaught we'll
just go from there what the city did not
prepare for was the intervention of Zorn
and that's when things really began to
pop off because when Zorn pops up I mean
for the most part that people are being
totally destroyed by the children of
tomorrow because the children tomorrow
are designed to be to be adaptable
they're designed to be hyper evolved and
so essentially what they do is adapt to
every single attack of the people they
analyze their powers they realize what
their powers are and then adapt
accordingly and so for the most part
being isn't as advanced as they are the
citizens of TN don't really stand a
chance here and in the face of defeat in
the face of realized in the handi the
odds are hopeless what Sauron does is
remove his mask and expose the
singularity
and literally just arts expanding
rapidly and consuming everything in its
path now this is not an infinite
singularity right it's not like a
traditional black hole where it just
constantly expands based on the amount
of mass it consumes it expands to a
point and then dissipates and that's
exactly what happens here when it starts
consuming everything around and it
basically destroys a huge portion of the
of the the city itself and cracks the
dome which is really the only thing they
needed the problem with this is that
Reed Richards was thinking ahead Reid's
idea was okay the federal government are
full of a bunch of idiots they're going
to attack because it's the only thing
they know how to do we'll move the city
into a position to where will conquer
essentially everything in our path will
present ourselves is such an extreme
credible threat that the government will
do the only thing it knows how to do and
it'll dump its entire arsenal their
entire arsenal will not be effective but
what that will mean is they have no real
retaliation of any kind whatsoever
inevitably the president's going to call
a meeting because he has to in order to
inform the Joint Chiefs or informed
Congress of what he's done and what this
is going to do is set the stage for
their total annihilation
and so what Reed has done is he
basically brings in one of the evolved
children which is essentially a walking
talking like teleporter and what this
guy is is he's carrying a weapon of mass
destruction and Reid says this is your
job this is the role that was assigned
to you is to be a weapon of destruction
Reid teleports the kid to Congress in
front of the president the House and the
Senate and detonates the kid and this
kid basically releases what what amounts
to a thermal nuclear explosion
annihilating the entirety of the US
federal government it's extreme there's
no functioning government in the United
States anymore it's gone now what this
will do and this is actually when Sam
Humphries begins to take over this sets
in motion the the return of Captain
America in the Ultimate Universe and the
second civil war in the United States
but this is kind of the transition what
you will usually see as you'll see a
transition between riders unless a rider
just fully takes over with like a new
run you'll see a transition in this
instance you have Jonathan Hickman who
was basically ultimates with Jonathan
Hickman and then you had Jonathan
Hickman and Sam Humphreys and so what
that meant was Marvel was transitioning
from Hickman's run into Humphreys run
and so the two of them kind of
collaborate where Hickman kind of writes
out his plot threads Sam Humphreys race
his in and that's where you started
getting into the idea of the Civil War
and so focusing almost exclusively on
what's going on with regards to what
Hickman is doing you have shield witches
and which is controlled by by Flum by
Marvin flung operating according to his
command it's really a dictatorship
you've got Nick Fury and The Ultimates
who are basically going underground and
then you've got Tony Stark now what Tony
Stark has done is essentially created in
a
in the form of a child and this is when
Hickman Spa threads get wrapped up quick
fast and in a hurry and so what
basically ends up going on here is you
have Tony Stark to reveal so Susan storm
that Reed Richards is the one who's
doing all this he's the one that
destroyed Washington DC and then you
have the newly appointed President of
the United States who basically steps in
and then makes it makes a peace treaty
of sorts with Reed Richards by
essentially handing over Tony Stark now
the handing over of Tony Stark was done
intentionally which is to say there's a
reason why it's Tony and nobody else
when it came to Reed Richards in the
Ultimate Universe kind of transitioning
to him becoming a bad guy the idea
behind this was that he was one of those
who was instrumental in essentially
sending Reed Richards out to the
negative zone kind of locking him away
when he first became a bad guy this is
what this has done this created a lot of
animosity between the two but the idea
behind Reed is to essentially break down
Tony Stark for all the evolution that
the children of tomorrow have they're
not Tony Tony Tony Stark is an absolute
genius duplicating his intelligence is
not easily done and so the intention of
Reed is to literally like dissect Tony
figure out what it is it makes him so
smart and then duplicate it this is very
very important the reason why is because
if Reed were able to take the
intelligence of Tony Stark and then
bring it inside his own brain it would
push him to a higher level of
intelligence which in turn would allow
him to introduce new concepts and new
ideas to the city itself and then in
turn hyper evolved it even further
because remember the motivations and the
mecha nations of Reed are not limited to
earth it's expanding outside earth into
the universe itself and literally like
conquering the entire universe and so
when all this goes on with Tony Stark
you essentially have this small child AI
that he's created which begins
communicating directly with the city
itself and so when that happens when
when this child AI starts talking to the
city and simply saying like we're
friends we can help each other this is
kind of interesting because one of the
things to bear in mind here is that for
all the all the the intelligence that
goes on with the various individuals
inside the city and the AI itself they
are essentially cut off from the world
there's a lot of experiences they've
never had and that's really the Achilles
heel of the city itself of the people in
it and the AI that runs it there's no
real exposure there all it knows is read
and whatever read tells it and so where
this kid shows up and says hey like we
can be friends and we should work
together and so on and so forth the city
goes along with it because it doesn't
really know how to interact or anything
like that now what the city does in turn
is begin developing weapons to work
against Reed Richards and literally
start manifesting various giant Iron Man
suits to attack read and when Reed tries
to seize control the city's response is
no you're unfit to be the leader and
this is a very important thing the
why the city comes to this conclusion is
because what the AI has been doing is
communicating directly with it and
telling it here are all the problems
that Reed has and here's how he works
directly against the city itself the
basis behind the city was to evolve
humanity to a higher level of existence
and then spread to the stars to
eliminate things like jealousy and envy
and base human emotions that would
basically work against its ability to
evolve on its on its own behalf
and become better Reed Richards is
governed by revenge which Reed should
not have based on the rules he's created
inside the city itself and those who
live in it and so what the AI is
essentially done is look at Reed and say
you work directly against the city
because all these emotions and these
attitudes you're displaying run directly
in in contradiction to one the rules
that we follow into the betterment of
the city itself and so in turn it turns
against Reed now again like well you
have the incredible whole kind of going
through and going crazy and attacking
everything and kind of losing its mind
what we end up finding out is this was
the entire motivation behind Tony Stark
the Tony Stark had gone to the President
of the United States and said Reed hates
me so hand me over to read like
literally go to go to Reed Richards and
say here's Tony Stark this is a peace
offering a way to find a truce between
the two of us Reed won't ask questions
because no matter what he says or what
he does or his intelligent as he is he's
still human he's still emotional and he
still hates me so he's just gonna go
with the flow and just accept this and
not really ask any questions and so
again it was it's it really kind of
comes out of left field and so in this
moment you have Susan storm who shows up
again really kind of showing how much
she hates read by you know really
grabbing him in his weakened state and
then putting him into a forcefield and
basically balling him up into a tiny
little ball so we can be imprisoned by
shield proper so again it really wraps
up fast it wraps up quick fast and in a
hurry there's not a whole lot to go on
here but it's pretty basic in terms of
the fact that it sets the stage for the
relationship between Nick Fury once he
retakes control of shield and then Reed
Richards himself during the events of
like Avengers and New Avengers when you
see him working alongside shield and
then you see him meeting like the Cabal
which is neighbor the Submariner Corvus
glaive Proxima midnight Thanos basically
the remnants of the Black Order
alongside Namor Namor himself but I
didn't set in the stage this is just
kind of kind of you know bringing this
little bit of information in and
allowing you guys to know what's going
on once we get into the actual events
involving Avengers and New Avengers and
how it is the Ultimate Universe fits
into it but without being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys have don't hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
purse
[Music]
[Music]